one
two three
four
five six
left foot goes over the body i'm staying
low
turning around
okay and i'm gonna go this way
left foot goes over the body i'm staying
low turning around
okay and i'm gonna go this way
okay
um okay so
my question
is why do we have these classes coming
up when we don't have finishing schools
coming up when most women can't cook
so actually you know that's more of a
statement but
i'm going gonna ask you guys would you
send your girl to that
wow
i'm not very funny
but i've never i've never had sex with a
sack of potatoes so
no i'm not sending my girls
what kind of club is the fact she had an
account
like
why do you need a count that's that's my
opening argument
you sending your girl um probably not
but i give them props for trying but
it's a bit shocking to think they've
they have to learn it
yo
it's just a bit wild isn't it yeah
it's just a bit wild
here's the thing right
it's the fact that like
you're you've got an instructor telling
you how to break your back out for your
for your partner
as much here's the thing right i don't i
wouldn't send my girl to it but if my
girl was going to a class like that
i wouldn't have no complaints about it
got it
i think it's more the modern
woman
there's there's that difference between
a modern woman and
women that was before like now and
everything is social media everything is
in your face to say this is what you
have to do and this is gospel um
would i do it as a woman as a 36 year
old woman probably not because i'm
probably like a you know an idiot and i
wouldn't want to embarrass myself but in
order to do that some people will look
at his oh i can make money to make sure
i can let other women feel this is the
way you meant to be as a woman
so
i also think it's a reflection of what
we as women think is valuable to a man
nowadays
we think that our value a lot of it
comes from sex and being attractive and
that goes back to why this is happening
going viral and not finishing school
because we've got this perception that
guys primarily like us or our only value
to get a guy to commit comes from are we
get in bed and are we attractive enough
and how quick can you do it yeah
yes
at least in my opinion quality men don't
value that as don't value that as much
as a girl who goes to you know finishing
school
and knows how to play the role of the
feminine in a relationship yeah well
because to guys like that like there's a
million girls that can i can't do that
yeah yeah
go ahead what's interesting to me is the
number of people in the class
like they've got some really good
marketing going on there i will say that
to add to your point is that a donny
there like what is is i mean that guy
there don't look doesn't he doesn't look
like he should be in that club
you know
i don't know but do you think it's more
embarrassing for the woman or the man
because you never know can the man be
feeling embarrassed in that video right
now because he hasn't said anything
the guy who's lying down i think it's
more embarrassing for the woman but she
doesn't know it
do you think no yeah yeah because
i just think like that's that's trashy
like yeah i just i just i just think
that's trashy and like if you want to
have a family someday like that's going
to be on the other hand forever
and so even if you don't have kids now
if you want to kids someday like that
that's your mom oh yeah like do you as a
man like want that to be a girl
but like for example if that was a
future husband that you found and he was
beneath that woman would you feel away
um
how do i put it i mean i wouldn't and do
i want the guy i'm married to be under
like no no
but but i don't think it holds the same
weight because i just think men and
women are different and so like to me
it's like oh i mean he's probably young
and just you know on wild [ __ ] but in
relation to that argument it's like
yo you you were under this beautiful
woman but at the same time you were just
there in a class in front of a whole
bunch of people i would i would have a
lot i would have a lot of questions
i would be like what was this
question is who's it who's it for who
are the ladies doing it for are they
doing it for their husbands their
partners are they doing it for fitness
and aerobic well i don't think they're
doing it for fitness and aerobics even
if if it's what they tell themselves
like people need this logical reason to
like justify why they do things if they
wanted to get fit they would go to the
gym lift some weights do some cardio it
wouldn't be this so i do think that
they're doing this because they want to
get better at sex which
it's not a problem in itself like if you
want to put in the effort to be better
in bed for your man than amazing but
it's more so what does it show when
women
value this
over
working on this substance
do you think most women know how to keep
a man outside of sex
to some extent no
what do you guys think in your your
experience dating absolutely not
i was waiting for all the man
i'm looking around the room like yeah
yeah cool
but no not at all
um
they haven't got the
it's it's com it's the competition that
annoys me because i feel like they're
trying to compete with us yeah rather
than joining the team right you know i'm
saying there's only one quarterback on
the nfl team right
i think more women are trying to be like
men with the masculinity yeah 100
i think what i think what hannah said is
really on on the money like
being of substance is really important
to high quality men and a lot of women
don't have that substance but they have
good looks
good physiques etc but what's beneath
the layers what where's the substance
behind it because that's in essence what
what men look for isn't it yeah i think
yeah yeah and to bounce off your point i
feel like what men look for
is
that substance but what women come with
is materialistic right do you know what
i'm saying i want a man with a nice car
a nice house a nice day all of that all
of that you gotta earn six figures
in the bank right the longest long since
king kong right do you know what i mean
where can you take me how much
but if i if i walk up and be like yo i
was a i was a pastry chef and i know how
to make every food underneath the sun
that that substance in in terms of its
value is worthless if i don't have any
financial
money to back it up do you know what i'm
saying so you're expecting oh you're a
chef so you should know you should take
me to nobu or to cover that meal for a
lot less i'm about to pay for it right
i mean and you can do those things but
it's about having the woman having the
substance to be able to have that
supported long term because a lot of
women will have
will have good looks and they will
attract a high quality man that they
like and pay attention to etc but the
question is can you sustain it and you
can only sustain it if you have
substance underneath of the good looks
that you already possess so i'm curious
um you said you're in a relationship or
you're married relationship what um
stood out about your girlfriend from the
other girls you were seeing yeah great
question substance
so she had a lot of depth to
conversation she had a lot of
understanding she had a lot of pic has a
lot of patience
and i think those qualities are
extremely rare
extremely rare
i also i
so i was talking to my boyfriend about
this and something that he said was
when we were first talking and like
flirting he said to me
if you couldn't use your
what's between your legs and your hands
what would you use to keep me interested
and
i i said my brain
and he was like oh that's a great answer
because most women would say their mouth
and that's a big reason why he said like
he continued to be interested in me
because we have that intellectually like
stimulating conversations
and when like with a woman it's not
about being super academically smart
like you don't have to be a doctor or
lawyer it's more about having things
going on for yourself and working on
your personal growth that's where that
intellectual
element comes from
do men care if you work on your personal
growth yes yeah absolutely it's
mandatory it's interesting because i
hear so many guys i just hear so many
guys say we don't care what you do
yeah it's not about it's not it's not
about what you do but it's who you're
being right so it's how you're behaving
in various environments you ask me you
know what stood out for me about
my missus is that she gets on with every
person that she comes into contact with
so for me
yeah so that's that's those little cues
that stand out you know what i mean and
a lot of people don't have that did you
care um would you is there such thing as
a girl that's too broke to date
no no no financially or
in different aspects
um
financially like too broke to date um
nothing to do with money at all thing no
um yeah i know a girl who is financially
broke
but every time we link up to like have a
chat called good friends know each other
for she for years and she's got me
employment
um out of our relationship but um yeah
she's always in a new relationship with
the next man
um recently he got in a relationship
five days in he's like he's like oh move
in yeah
right
it's not
the the financial brokenness can
sometimes interlink with
if they're being if they're mentally
broke like if they've been financially
broke for a long period of time and they
don't have mental stimulation and they
don't have drive and they don't have
ambition and they don't have
uh relational skills etc that's where it
becomes a problem but if they have all
of those skills relational skills etc
understanding patients and so on but
they're financially broke then
men don't really care about that do you
know what's funny it's insane that i
would say um she is what i would
consider someone who is definitely
wifeable because she's all in her
feminine energy but at the same time
she's very
masculine in it in the sense of she will
get [ __ ] done when it needs to get done
sure for swearing but um yeah
why do you think there's so many women
that are in their masculine energy
nowadays
it's
i think more and more women have been
told that in order for them to get
credit they have to be super career
driven
they have to make loads of money they
have to focus on achievement and so when
women pursue that they tend to be in
their masculine energy a lot and being a
stay-at-home wife or raising a family it
doesn't it's not seen as as valuable
but i i would argue insane
to some point i agree with you but argue
and say that if women are
single parents
um and had to raise their children by
themselves they're looked upon as
masculine as well but they're being at
home raising the family and
to some for often of their own or not on
their own like the the father of their
children is not there but they still
have to raise the children but they are
willing to be that housewife etc um
but they looked upon us being masculine
because they're saying well you're a
single parent and you're a single parent
for a reason so i feel sometimes as a
female regardless what role we play is
sometimes hard to kind of say all right
which way do we go do we go down the
feminine route or do we have to go down
sometimes the messages
though
like femininity and masculinity it's all
contextual and it's not black and white
so for me personally in business i show
up as pretty masculine like you know the
very typical boss business babe whatever
and then in my relationship i'm the
opposite and that's because i had to
unlearn a lot of the
social programming that told me that my
worth came from career success
and i had to relearn like what men
really want in a relationship which is
they want a woman to make them feel
appreciated supported they want a woman
to like bring out his masculine even
more and play the feminine role
they really look down
on being the mother now if you just
wanted to go home and you work maybe
part-time if you can't afford to do it
and then
everyone just looks down on you on that
that's a bad thing to do you've done
that for a man i find
that's yeah because my friend ali i was
telling you guys before the show she
went viral for just saying yeah my um my
husband's my boss i work for him yeah he
makes the decision
yeah yeah
i was the one behind the camera yeah
yeah that was that was my
all the comments were basically saying
how could you trust him like well he
could just leave you high and drive but
it's like everything you do has risk
like there's risk in being a single
parent there's ever like you can get
married you could get divorced like
life is risk i think what we're talking
about here with what you said lavina
what you said hannah is about emotional
intelligence so it's being able to
switch on and switch off and apply
yourself effectively in different
situations and scenarios whether it's
masculine energy or feminine yeah yeah
and just understanding the two and then
when to play which role accordingly yeah
sometimes i feel
men struggle with that as well
like
you're absolutely right men do want to
feel like they are the man and they want
to feel wanted and they want to feel
like their purpose in the relationship
but sometimes there are some men if
they've never been shown that as
a young person or a child they won't
know how to do that as an adult and
sometimes as a woman we can be patients
about i can show you that but if they're
not willing to receive
that love from it's very hard
relationships are just a thing that not
a lot of people taught and because
people don't do the self-development
work on themselves they expect something
else somebody else outside of them to
validate who they are and what they do
whereas they don't have that internal
self belief that internal validation
which is which is important yeah in
saying that as well i feel like based on
the solely of personal experience right
um as a young man i used to wear glasses
isn't it so
throughout my whole secondary school
year i had glasses on so i didn't really
have the confidence to be like to
approach women in that sort of way and
format because and then the moment i
turned 19 got laser eye surgery
lost my glasses
hit the gym i mean did all these things
i never used to do and then and realized
i was like yo i'm kind of i'm kind of a
spice right now
i'm kind of good
to say and i never went to uni and then
i lost my virginity when i was at uni
and then that just opened up a whole new
dose of experience that i didn't
experience before so
um when it comes to the younger men
coming up nowadays i feel like yeah they
have no
because they have no guidance do you
know what i mean they have no one to say
well how how are they supposed to be
taught about women if like i i want to
say aren't half of people raised by
single mothers or like
that i was gonna get to that point
i'm raised by a single mother
when it came to asking my dad about for
stuff like hey dad
you know what i mean how does it do to
you know do certain sexual activities
with a woman
do you know he wasn't around
straight up i'll say it
no problem i said it on my channel i'm
saying on post yeah
women have been been encouraged to go
off and be independent on their own
and if their meaning was to you know
find a husband have children look after
children and their men were to
get a job find a wife and then provide
for them and the women have gone off the
men have nothing now to look what
doesn't there's no wives around
so they're just completely helpful what
percent of women would you say
want to be wives and what percent of
women would you say our wives i want to
hear from the men
and your experience with dating
carry on the conversation that's you
right there i'm choosing the girl
i'm choosing to go last i bet a lot
lie to themselves
so i bet it's higher than they think
so i'm gonna say about 80 percent want
to be wives yeah
only furry
30 are wives yeah okay yeah i think i
would
i would agree a lot with that i think a
lot of women want to be wives but they
don't have the substance or the skills
to actually
support the lifestyle
of the person that they would ideally
like to be with so then they end up with
somebody that is not fully compatible
with and they go oh my relationship's
all right it will it will last and you
know we have our ups and downs and they
have those sorts of tumultuous
relationships that don't really work out
long term
but most women don't have the the skill
sets to be
wives to the men that they aspire to be
with and what skills would you say those
are
patients communication i think
communication is one of the most the
most powerful ones because
a lot of women have
in my experience at least have a lot of
self doubt and they don't
they don't know how to be supportive to
somebody else they don't know how to
communicate powerfully with somebody
else in a way that
helps their relationship to grow helps
their relationship to flourish and helps
their relationship to be really
effective
do you think women have self-doubt
because i find them to be more
narcissistic than ever
yeah is it is it a fake narcissistic
though because it's like an external
narcissism but an internal i don't feel
good about this i don't feel i'm worth
it
no
i feel like
i'll just like even at carnival i was
asking like rate yourself one to ten and
they would say ten i'm like oh god again
okay and then i'd ask i'd say well
aren't you perfect doesn't mean you're
perfect she's like well i'm not perfect
but i am and then they'd say special but
isn't it kind of narcissistic to think
you're special yeah like
everyone thinks they're special like
it's been proven in psychology that
everyone thinks they're above average
yeah i think they like to fib a lot to
not hurt everyone's feelings so
i i was single for six years nothing and
then
this year i've just started getting back
into the dating game but the ones who
did text back all said the same thing i
would happily be your friend we never
talked again so why say we're not going
to be friends we know we're not going to
be friends
and to say hannah you say everyone
thinks they're above average when i rate
myself i fully give myself a 5.
because i don't feel like i'm better
than anyone and i don't feel like anyone
should be better than me probably a four
so four yeah are you rating yourself for
four you're saying no you're definitely
more than a four bro i know
when it comes to rating
what criteria are we using like are we
using what scale of one or ten in terms
of how good we are as a partner or how
attractive we are what's creating i'm
always talking about looks
okay so i'm always just talking about
looks wonderful yeah okay i will still
rate myself for five because here what
cool i got hype but i'm scoring it in
comparison to most most people i've
interact with right
um
again i'm not i haven't even got a full
beard my beard don't connect so already
i'm out
of the market
so so i don't actually think you
answered what percent of women do you
think our wives what person want to be
wives and what percent are and then i'm
gonna let the girls answer yeah i didn't
answer that um i think 100 of women want
to be wise with contingencies a hundred
percent you think the girls in those
videos want to be wives
yeah
okay
with the contingencies in the sense of
like they run me 10 grand a month
yeah
but that's not a real wife right so like
what percent of women actually want to
be wives you have to say like actually
want to be a wife with what it comes
with in the traditional sense
um i would say be what men want
what was it i think i heard like what
did you say john
i think i said it's james by the way
sorry sorry i still apologize that's
right um i said 70 i think 17 or 18 and
30. actually and then just i would say
81 and less than 10 percent yeah i'm
going with 25.
25. one and four one and four are wives
one and four always and what percent
want to be
the rest oh you think all girls want to
i don't think all girls want to be wives
i feel like they won't i just i can't
you can't be doing this [ __ ] i want to
deal with
i just
yeah 100
it is just like
like and you look at girls instagrams
and like the way it's like
oh you can't you can't see
but at the same time i'm still sticking
in like
here's the fence right you're right okay
okay i'm hopeful
like here's the fence we already know
only fans have really made how many
billion from for women but i'm still
like
i'm getting closer to the feds but i'm
still on i'm still off the fence
i'm hopeful
i mean i've been growing up on christian
values so yeah what about you guys what
do you think so just to be clear are you
asking what percentage of women like
want to be wives in the sense that they
want to be stay at home full-time um not
necessarily
stay at home like they want to be a
man's help mate i would say that's the
best way to put it i make money you help
me make money yeah and so whether like
some some girls are wives in the fact
they're more like executive assistant
type wives okay some girls are wives and
the fact you know their stay at home my
mom type wives
like it's not it's not a one some some
do the you know like they both get a job
you know and just but but the the key is
that they're submitting to the man oh i
think
around 40 40 of women want that or
actively know they want that
because most women think that submission
is a bad thing
okay they think that they they want to
be empowered and they think that
submission means being a man's slave
so i think only 40 of women
have that awareness to realize that like
it's not a bad thing
and to the second percentage i would say
10 percent actually our wives yeah
and why do you say that why is it so
little
because
nowadays most women like a most women
have this oh i'm a strong independent
woman vibe
where they tell themselves they don't
even want a relationship in the first
place or they want to focus on their
careers
of the women who want to be in
relationships they still think that
submission or femininity is backwards or
a bad thing so i think only 10 of women
actively want that and they have that
yeah it seems quite london-centric as
well like women that that want to be the
boss they want to be the leader they
want to be
more career driven et cetera and less
sort of alluding to wanting to be wives
are like london has that in abundance
more like outside the countryside it's a
little bit different
yeah what do you think
i would say
about 25
are probably married
i would say about 45
are wanting to be married but not in
that status
and the rest are not interested of being
married simply because
um that divide between being the wife
and being maybe the side chick
and
some women
probably um prefer to be the sergeant
because they feel like well i can just
have the fun bit i don't have to do all
the other bits that comes into a
relationship and it's not because
they devalue themselves but they feel
like
maybe some insecurities in themselves
where they feel that they are not enough
to be off so they'll settle for second
mess when they forward i can still have
the man i want in my kind of head but
just have it on that kind of tip do you
think women want that long term
well being a sergeant yeah
um reality it wouldn't happen in their
head they think it would happen for some
of them um
which is a harsh truth but it's the
reality for some women and i think
because of maybe ongoing heartbreaks or
putting their
heart and soul into someone that they
thought they could trust and build and
just constantly being put down or
putting themselves down
and
they just think you know what it is what
it is and that's how some women how some
women have
come in reality in society
do you guys think we'll ever see the
pendulum swing back where instead of sex
schools we'll start to see finishing
schools come back
we'd like to see finishes
i did the bouquet of flowers real quick
so we're starting wife school on a
second channel shout out
but you don't think so why
the way
society is moving it's making if we look
at the trend more and more men are
being feminized in the sense that
they're
encouraged to talk about their emotions
freely and they're encouraged to
cross-dress and where pain can try
different clothes and women more and
more are encouraged to
excel in their careers
can i add to that point real quick right
as a test to that theory i i text one of
my good friends female friends right
to be fair it was it was a it was an
experiment and it was an actual call for
help right because i was like i just
lost my uh one of my greatest grand
grand arnies
um one of my best artists but it's
technically grant are you however you
work the family system right
um she passed away
and and i and i hit her up like hey
listen
i need to just cry for a minute
have female company
and that's about it
not in a sense not in a sexual sense but
in the sense of i can't cry to my mom
because she's also crying about her
auntie do you know what i mean
but i needed i needed to
have the ex girl excursion and this was
like a girl you were seeing no no this
was just a female friend oh okay right i
wouldn't do it to a girl scene that
would just ruin the whole relationship
but
don't consider that as toxic masculinity
it's not okay um
but at the same time in the back of my
head it was a social experiment because
i i i kind of knew she wasn't gonna hit
me up and be like yeah come come around
cry for a little bit
and then we'll and then we'll like you
know smoke up and then all blessings you
know what i mean like it
it kind of hit me and i was like this is
maybe have i grew up wrong in the sense
of i'm as a man i'm not supposed to show
emotion
or women not supposed to receive the
emotion that i'm feeling but this is the
issue people feel that because you're a
man you can't show your emotions that's
why
there's a lot of people that do suffer
with mh right now because they're not
able to express or they're not being
told to express because especially
emotions it shouldn't be looked upon as
a weakness but the thing is like women
aren't meant to handle man's emotions
like women i'm not meant to but you can
be i mean you can talk teach yourself
you're kind of going against nature
though and that's what's confusing to
men like there's study after study after
study that's going to tell you that
women lose respect it's not fun this
isn't like a fun part of female nature
but they lose respect for men after
we've seen them cry and a lot of girls
will say they haven't looked at the guy
the same
and like you know i could be like
dishonest and and come and say oh yeah
like it's perfectly okay to express your
emotions but it's just not like to for
from a man to express his emotions to
i'm not saying like you can't ever show
any but like if you want to cry in front
of your girl is that a good bet
not not in general so would you look at
a man differently if a man cries in
front of you
um
i would say my dad is one of the people
that i respect more than anyone in the
world like i i listen to like pretty
much whatever he tells me
most of the time
um but
and i would say one of the reasons i
respect him is he's just always been
very in control of his emotions i can
count i've seen my dad cry
maybe once at his mom's when his mom
died and that's it and i just think like
that level of respect wouldn't happen if
he was crying once a month twice a year
like it just wouldn't be the same right
there is exceptions to when they're
allowed to cry yeah they don't have to
be stone-cold all the time yeah yeah but
it's like
i just think as a girl you trust men
more when they're in control of their
emotions because if i feel like i'm more
like you're more emotional than me
it's like
it's a tough like to trust your judgment
no i agree with that and i'm not saying
a man should cry every month same way a
woman shouldn't cry every month if
there's nothing to cry about
but
the way i look it with your emotions
like if something severe happens some
men do believe i'm not going to share a
tent
and to to me it's like
but why not because you're still human
at the end of the day you're not made
out still yeah well i i think the
problem though is it's very confusing to
men because we don't even know where the
line is
and women yeah women in general like you
don't know exactly like this is the line
where i start to lose respect for you i
couldn't tell you
i couldn't tell you at what point like
this is like i don't think i don't if a
dude like lost his mother am i gonna you
know judge him for crying no
but i don't know what point you but i
know there's a point
it's about being able to control your
emotions without suppressing them isn't
it right so it's like okay i'm feeling
i'm feeling this way because of x and
these are the things that i can do to
solve it rather than oh i'm feeling this
way so i'm just going to cry do you know
what i mean like having having a
solution-oriented mindset is what
what men want and what women also look
for in a man as well is being able to
lead being able to be decisive being
able to
so you yeah so it's just an animal to
your point hence that's hence why
i didn't go to like a family member or
like
someone someone who was also sharing the
same emotion i was because at the same
time
like
people who are going to watch this late
one we'll be like yo that's the backbone
that's the backbone of the family right
there so for me to show emotion and to
cry
i better be
i don't think it's a fun part of female
nature like i don't think this is a very
flattering part of ourselves but it just
you know it just kind of is and i and
i'm from uh my my family older head of
the family are female
i'm the oldest boy
so do you feel like the family like
looks up to you to lead would you say
sometimes yeah
if not nine times out of ten
if there's a family barbecue i'm the i'm
the chef so you're grilling so i'm
saying it comes to christmas
ash
do this xyz one two and three yeah i'm
getting it done because that's what it's
expected of a man yeah to get [ __ ] done
leadership
that that's my point you know so when it
comes to family
yeah i am the head of my household
even even if the even if i am the uncle
of my nephew's
children
you can call me granddad it's all good
because i've been granddad's from when i
was 14 because of my personality and
nature and the fact i wore glasses
hannah so you mentioned you talk about
submission on your tick tock account
what is the general response you get
women hate it
they'll say something like
this is misogyny
or standing what submission is in the
context of a healthy relationship
they they think submission and they
think oh
being a slave or lowering yourself for a
man
or
being at his backing call or having no
opinions when submission in a
relationship isn't about that at all it
really means that you're just trusting a
man's leadership and that you respect
him to the point where even when you
have disagreements you're not nagging
you're not shouting at him you're not
emasculating him so
when women understand that then the word
in itself submissive it's so
it triggers people
so i know you said um you mentioned deep
you had to deprogram a lot of that stuff
what was like the turning point for you
when i the turning point for me was when
i built my own business i scaled it very
successfully
and because i got so much praise for it
i kept thinking okay my value to a man
comes from how much money i make the
more money i make the more they're gonna
see me as different from the other women
so the turning point for me was when i
looked at my history of dates and
thought to myself why is it that no man
like me what if it's not the man's fault
what if it's my fault so then i started
reading books on dating and books on men
so i could understand men and women and
the common theme that kept coming up was
that masculine men don't like masculine
women they like women a woman who's in
touch with a feminine and a woman who's
open to receiving so then i started
making those changes in myself and
that's when i actually
got a boyfriend
that's really powerful because most
women don't do that they don't do that
self-reflection they don't read most
people don't read the books about
relationships but most people want a
healthy successful relationship but they
never research or read books on healthy
successful relationships and most women
want a they want a a man that is that is
able to lead they want a masculine man
but then if they're not going to be
submissive to somebody who's leading
then it doesn't actually make sense if
they're not going to be submissive so if
you're like if a woman is like okay well
i don't want to be submissive well then
what you're saying is you want a a man
that is equal or below you
yeah but then they'll go no no no no but
i need a man that makes six figures but
you don't make six because this doesn't
actually make sense
yeah not to mention submission is a very
beneficial thing for the woman too if
you're super career driven if you're
making a ton of decisions if you have to
lead a team in your business don't you
want to relax when you're outside of
business and let a man handle things
like
i also think like
to add on to what you said people suck
at taking accountability
we always ask ourselves like on my tech
talk so i post like dating stuff for
women
a lot of women will comment saying oh
where do you find your boyfriend where
can i find these men all men are trash
but no woman saying
what do i need to do in order to become
in order to attract a better quality man
it's like a submissive submissive
there's only one person can drive a car
at a time so you can't grab the wheel
off of them
so
people find it a weird word to use but
only one person can be in control what
do you say to women that say they want
an equal partnership
then you have to deal with the fact
you're not going to get the traditional
benefits of a man like
he he's going to want to split the bill
he's good
i love that like it's true right like
he's if you want to be equals with a man
then you're not don't expect the
benefits that a masculine provider man
is going to give you
you can't have something without giving
something else back absolutely you know
to add to your point right now i just
had a little brainwave and i was like
yo i can technically build a house
but i don't own six figures a month
or six figures a year not even close
but it's this it's the type of women
that goes for the six figures men it's
not every woman that has that mentality
of like i need to have a man that has
six figures you can get a man that's his
figures and maybe can't even construct a
sentence together i mean i think that's
what women say but then you watch who
they date and it's a different story
i've seen a lot of girls come on my show
and they'll like say something that
sounds nice and then after i'll look at
their dating history and maybe he's not
rich but he sure as hell is quite
handsome and like top 10 20
and so maybe it's not rich but
like
yeah i mean
not to not to disclose any any
information that's only two stars about
me but um
up until like a year and a half ago i
didn't have a bed
but yeah i was still
engaging with sexual activities with
women
to the point where they were like you
should get a bed
i will get back
not right now because i don't need one
i'm not in a relationship it wasn't
until i got into a full-on relationship
i was like yo i'm i can marry you
tomorrow and not feel no type of way
about it i don't care what my family say
i don't care what they got to say i'm in
love with you and you are
in terms of
the roles of the relationship
like she was willing to learn
i was willing to learn
and she was feminine
and i was masculine yeah you know i'm
saying like for example we
i would finish a hard day at work she
would finish hard at work
my house or your house your house okay
cool yeah i get around there food's
cooked
my favorite lemon drizzle cake whatever
and then you know what i mean it was it
was feminine and she come to mind i'd do
the same thing because that was our
roles in relationship in the sense of we
don't live together but in this but if
if i'm coming to you abode you can't
afford me yeah do you know what i mean
so
in that sense i was like yeah life is
good why don't you why don't you need a
bed for and that mattress on the floor
is good
that bed soon came though and that woman
came to them
she said
she said one line i said okay cool
next day i'm on ebay looking for beds
you see is that that
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier right about communication skills
yeah you see some
a lot of women would communicate things
in an aggressive way which doesn't cater
to for one of a better word than male
ego so therefore they're not gonna get
them whereas if she says it in a certain
way or ask a certain question rather
than makes a statement then it becomes
like okay i want to do this for myself
and for us rather than i'm being forced
to do it by somebody else all she said
is babe you need a bed
that's it
that communication thing i don't think a
lot of people are very honest in
relationships anymore
so
i uh
i was dating this girl a few few for
about three weeks i was seeing her on
the weekend before she moved away and
for the first two weeks she mentioned
she said the words no i don't want to
have sex she said it's okay for me not
to have sex and the second one she said
is it all right for us to never have sex
and i said what never that's a long time
i joked about it
and then the third week were more
intimate than i thought but we didn't
have sex
and i kept talking to her
and eventually i had a conversation with
her saying like what would you have
improved of me if i could find something
out and she said i never made a move
and i was just and she doesn't remember
saying
no i didn't want to have sex
i think she was just playing games i
think she's yeah
yeah that sounds like a player
there is some you're playing checkers
she's playing chelsea
yeah um i'm gonna take a second and read
super chats so um guys all super chats
are going towards updates in the studio
blessing
which you want another camera right
two
all right blessing wants two more
cameras
so
it's just
wild and out i guess
he's trying to stretch stretch the
budget he's been he's he's been
stretching the budget
he has been stretching
that pay rise
um okay guys so all that's what all
super chats are going towards it really
helps um just fun the different upgrades
that we want to do in the studio another
thing is i really want to get a logo put
behind me so like that'd be cool um
so
super chat from lat dior
art to dress
edit one is based on oh i see a lot of a
lot of women mistake submission for
subservience one is based on trust and
the latter and one is based on trust and
ladder on trust submission is given
subservience is taken and demanded the
submission submissive sets the
boundaries of trust edit one is oh one
is based on control one is untrust
henry lucy
a man should be stoic and under no
circumstances should he cry in front of
his female the gentleman with the dreads
took an l the minute he mentioned his
female friend beta um
the savvy ninja the movie's fury and
saving
private ryan showing shows exactly how a
man should handle his emotions they both
cried in a private away from the those
they led
oh that's an interesting thing i've
never thought about it like do you want
to see your boss cry
i've seen my boss
yeah but
she was female
and that's what yeah um
because i'm just like thinking
now i work for myself but i'm just
thinking that'd be so weird if i saw my
manager cry back in the day
um radcawa being emotional is a weakness
any choice made with emotion and worse
than if you used cold logic why are men
taught to be their worst selves khaled
al josef the world is precious but most
the most precious thing in the world is
a virtuous woman and that's a unicorn
sadly as most women have lost their
virtuous um the savvy ninja everyone is
unique i rate myself an eight being
unique or special doesn't give you a
pass or a license to be delusional
however many girls think it does
love the content um
or sydney cindy jacob love the content
red cowa women like the idea of being
wives like they like the idea of being
ceos the job looks good but it's hard
work and most wouldn't want to do let
alone work up to
thank you
kelon sydney thank you for the super
chats
centipede not sure if i'll be able to
watch this stream unfortunately so have
a good one i'm going to refresh it
really quick while you're at it guys we
have over a thousand people in here so
we should have a thousand likes a like
is free okay it takes you two seconds to
just like the video all right you don't
you don't want to have beef with me okay
like
it's syria it's serious beef so it came
it came medium rare on the plate and it
was i was in the concierge it came
medium rare on my plate yeah literally
you subscribed right but i subscribed
before i got it
yeah
yeah i've been on protein all week
freeman art pearl um how did this how
did this panel of capping bettas sneak
out of the house um kyle murray um thank
you for the super chat um coleman's get
pearl a higher chair her poor knees
um
maybe i should get a higher chair um
john smith we're never having sex why
didn't you make a move three out of
fours out here are wild um okay those
are all the super chats so um i think
we're going to react to the second clip
um this is from hannah's tick-tock
[Music]
it was funny hannah came on my show like
last week and then i was scrolling on
tic tac and i was like oh my gosh this
girl was on my show
the algorithm knows yeah
not a better by the way
[Music]
does it go oh i think the sound might be
off i think jess might have turned it
off earlier
when i have lived in this apartment for
two years before him and i paid 100 for
myself we believe right it's gonna be
the provider of the relationship who
pays for the dates uh he does 100 who
manages the housework cooking
stuff making the house look pretty so
that's almost all on me with cleaning we
outsource it to a cleaner
from the beginning with cooking i cook a
lot of the time or we just order it yeah
my boyfriend and i practice polarization
in our relationships which means that
instead of going 50 50 on everything we
go 100 100 on our respective roles talk
about who works and who brings in money
we both run our own businesses so we
both make money that said we mainly
spend his money so i have his bank
attached to my apple pay and we just
have separate bank accounts and let's
talk about rent and bills he pays 100 of
the rent and the bills before anyone
calls me like a gold digger or says that
i'm dependent on him when i have lived
in this apartment for two years before
him and i paid 100 for myself we believe
in the man being the provider of the
relationship who pays for the dates uh
he does 100 who manages the housework
cooking cleaning making the house look
pretty so that's almost all on me with
cleaning we outsource it to a cleaner
and also laundry as well but with
cooking i cook a lot of the time or
i don't keep going then i'll manage it i
choose it but we use his credit card in
terms of who plan things i would say
it's more like 60 40 or 70 30 where he
plans things most of the time but
whenever he doesn't want to or he
actively wants me to do it then he'll
tell me to plan it or if there's just
something that like i really want to do
or i feel like planning it then i'll do
that something that i want to add is
there's no right or wrong way the most
important thing is that both of you feel
like you're getting equal value exchange
and that both people are putting in
equal effort
my boyfriend and i practice polarization
in our relationship which means that
instead of going 50 yeah um just off the
bat oh i think it's still going it's
only the tv it's not going on mine oh
okay okay yeah i was just saying you can
exit out of the actual tab
yeah thank you sorry go ahead go ahead
but um no just saying what you're saying
there you smashed it out the tub
as as someone who is currently
unemployed
um
living in my mom's basement as i would
call it
whatever
don't drive whatever you know i mean i'm
not i'm not the london geezer but you
still smashed it out because that's
exactly how i would act
as a man and what i would expect from my
woman
yeah and i also just want to put that
video into context because when i
uploaded it i purposely made it look
like he was providing a lot when i
downplayed my part
i posted a second video which solely
focused on what a woman brings to the
table and that's when i went into my
role in depth supporting
you know other things like that
and what i noticed was that in the first
video i got a lot of hate from men
but in the second video i got a lot of
hate from women interesting
how did you get a lot of hate from men
for your first one because it seems like
he was bringing most of the things to
the table i ain't saying she'll go
digger
but but what but why would that be why
would that be a problem
so what i was trying to show was that
people lack accountability
and they are so quick to want to take
from the other person but they don't
want to reflect on themselves yeah but
also
most people who hate don't understand
that
men and women have different or like
they value different currencies in a
relationship
so
for a woman her way of being taken care
of is the man being the provider because
it represents that he's investing his
resources in her right but for a man
what he cares about is a woman who 100
supports his mission
and does the small things for him every
day like you know bring him a glass of
water when he's working hard or
tell him that he's gonna meet his
business goals when he's doubting
himself and things like that
and people tend to value money way too
much when it comes to
like what value someone brings to their
relationship they think that money is
the only valuable currency there is to
offer
it's really valuable what you said as
well in terms of there is no right or
wrong way it's about finding the
finding the balance that works for you
and your relationship but here's the
thing most people don't actually think
about the balance that works in their
relationship here's how most people go
into relationship they go
in their mind they say okay my parents
did it this way and the people around me
did it this way so this is what i expect
from you as a man and a man goes yeah
but my that did it that way so this is
what i expect from you as a woman but
they don't actually talk about it they
just have false expectations that have
no communication behind them and then
they get surprised when it falls apart
but should you have expectations in
relationships because sometimes well you
shouldn't have expectations that aren't
clearly communicated
but then if you have expectations
sometimes people really have
expectations
it's like you're expecting it to
not go to plan because if you expect
something you're expecting it to go plan
and if you don't that's when people go
sour that's when people will be like
what's the point of doing this and have
that kind of negative attitude towards
certain things i understand i understand
what you're saying but you have to be
clear on in terms of certain things you
have to be clear on what it is that you
want in your relationship what's
acceptable what's not acceptable what
i'm saying is that most people aren't
clear on what is acceptable and what
isn't acceptable in their relationships
because they don't actually discuss it
they just think oh well i've grown up
like this so this is what i expect but i
don't actually have that clear class and
this is what hannah was saying is have
that discussion so that you're very very
clear about what it is that both of you
bring to the table what it is that both
of you want no i agree with you and i
think sometimes those discussions do
happen
but again it comes back to what you said
about accountability people don't take
accountability to actually
really admit to what they want and what
they don't want they have an image of
what they want they have a visual of
what they think a relationship should
look like and when it's put into the
table to them
they actually think actually i can't
actually handle this i can't actually
match to what i think i can do
because they haven't been able to go
into themselves and take accountability
for what they can or cannot do
agreed
it's also like a lot of men want a
submissive woman but they don't have the
qualities that would make a woman submit
to him
and also a lot of women want a man who
pays for her and provides for her and is
a good leader plans the dates but they
also don't want to do the work to be the
kind of woman that yeah the masculine
man wants either facts yeah
so to summarize your your point nicely
in the terms of my personal dating
experience
right i got to a point when i
where um i came back from from uni um a
bit after i should have actually came
back from uni but i came back anyways
and then i was on tinder hinge or
whatever whatever and i was going
through my um the one night stand dating
experience right i never had a one night
stand before i came back to london after
i figured i was for like 35 or whatever
yeah
so
women were complimenting me for the fact
i made them breakfast in the morning
and that to me was bewildered because
who doesn't want breakfast in the
morning like basically
yeah but then i realized it was like am
i introducing eyes
like am i simping for the fact that i
had a mum and my mom always used to say
to me if you're cooking
cook for everyone facts
you know what i'm saying
so if you're staying in that mind but
but a lot of those a lot of those kind
of
rituals if you like have been somewhat
lost in society and a lot of people
don't have those same those same norms
and values hundred percent hundred
percent but at the same time i follow
that's what makes a man a man that's i
do that you go
i don't want you to cook breakfast bro
they want to go to dick riding classes
man
i'm presenting you as in what i can
provide as a man i can give you what
you're about to pay 11 pounds for brunch
for do you know
what what do you guys see as solutions
in the dating market going forward
do you think it starts with the women or
the men
both they both need to equally read
books and educate themselves on what the
opposite sex wants
i would it would be amazing if people
can go on relationship courses before
they went on relationship before they
actually got into relationships like i'm
talking like early 20s do you know what
i mean if that was like part of like you
know adulthood and you know people who
go into a career and stuff like that why
don't you go into 90 of relationship
courses are garbage they probably are
but
i just think that's easy money yeah
honestly but but i mean in terms of
maybe not you know some it would be a
course some it would be books some would
be um you know personal research and
stuff like that but people don't
actually take the time to actually just
i feel like it would make more sense for
them to talk to someone who's been
married 50 years as well yeah
and most people don't have that no one
yeah
that's what a problem lies and that's
the crazy thing is i talk to so many
girls that like think it's okay to leave
just because you're not happy
especially when you have kids
and it's it's just like my mom always
told me once you have kids it's not
about you and so i just get really
confused when i and like you're not
happy i'm like the ladies from the 1940s
and 50s would think we're so weak today
like my man had a side chick across town
because you're not happy
i've met someone who was like oh um as
long as he
left the house at certain time
came back at a certain time and paid the
bills
whatever he did in that time is none of
my business
my my um
no i said my no i'm not going to tell it
it's not no it's not about me
i think i think that side of the i think
that side of the family would get banned
i've got stories for you let me know
i'll come back here next week just
basically basically um
there there was a a relative that yeah
if i don't say that relative i think
it'll be okay
there's a relative of mine that she she
knew her husband was cheating right and
um basically that
the the husband left and this girl was
like a devout catholic like she she like
very much prayed
every day like the most catholic person
i've ever met
and the
the husband left the family to be with
the side chick
and she prayed for a solution
side chick died
yeah and he came home and they were
married like 50 plus years i mean that's
don't doubt the bible that's what i'm
saying yeah and it's just like like the
women back then were willing to like
like she put up with that to be with him
i i
that'd be a little far even for me but
maybe that's like a sign of the times
right hannah you're you're in the
relationship yeah
and if your um partner decide actually
i'm gonna have a side chick how would
you feel about it
he wouldn't do that but if he did i
would not be okay with it okay so do you
think so do you think that would be
i'm out of this relationship
yeah
so would you say that hannah's weak if
she was to walk away from her
relationship her partner had the side
chick
no no no right right now now i mean
because i think like she's in a position
she can be selective but if you have
kids yeah i think it's selfish
i think like once you have kids it's not
about you anymore but like before you
have kids like before you have kids yeah
you can if you if what if someone that's
faithful is a priority to you and you
don't have kids involved yeah go get it
there's plenty of guys that'll be
faithful i know i know the man of sphere
says like all guys cheat whatever but i
know a lot of good dudes that won't
cheat on you
yeah
i think people say all men cheat because
that's what they've known like all men
in your life cheap but that doesn't mean
that all men on the planet cheat
and also in the media we hear a lot more
stories of guys who cheat than guys who
don't so then we have this like
distorted idea that all men cheat and
then because that's what a woman
believes that's what she's gonna attract
well and then the girls what they'll do
is when they cheat
the answer is always well why did she
cheat
and it's like
it doesn't
okay so you're going jess go on
not going all right because i was going
to make a point it's more for
this is going to sound like hell hella
andrew take style yeah
but it's more for women to cheat than a
for a man to cheat it's more for a woman
to cheat than for manchester
saying yes yes
we as men are not emotional creatures
facts you know what i'm saying we we
will tell you we love you we don't
straight up
i've told plenty of women over my ears
babies i love you you know one for me
you know i mean give her all the sweet
talk we don't mean none of it
and i'm out here man out you know what
i'm saying
i don't care i'm this i'm 30 years old
now i'm i'm literally marry me ma [ __ ]
me or leave me yeah
it's like a lot of women talk about okay
you know um
they hate on like you know this man
cheating kind of situation but what i
think a lot of people miss is that men
are it's like a lack of scale right men
are significantly less likely to cheat
the more solid the more powerful the
more engaged their their partner is you
know if you've got a woman that's 100
120
the
the chance of a man cheating just slims
down significantly do you know what i
mean but a lot of a lot of people don't
look intrinsically to say what what what
am i doing in this relationship that
actually is not making it effective for
my partner whether that's male or female
and one in four marriages are sexless i
think they said twenty percent so almost
one in four there you go so it's like a
lot of times girls will you know go to
court and say he cheated right you you
didn't sleep with him for two years what
was he supposed to do
what's your thoughts about that though
that sounds like a me
for man cheats regarding what pearl just
said
in the sense of you're not giving it up
yeah well then obviously yeah if you're
not giving it up um a man is going to go
elsewhere because
men and women are functioning
differently
men are function to need to have a
release it might not just be emotional
sense it could be that it's just they
need to release because of the
frustration that they feel because our
bodies are designed differently what
what's what's worse
emotionally or physically right so
what's worse right um
you're you're hypothetically speaking
your man is constantly texting this
other girl and building up an emotional
relationship they've never kissed
they've never had a physical intimacy
but they've been going back and forth
for the last six months or he goes to
miami has a one-night stand doesn't even
have a phone number what's worse
emotional straight up what's worse
hannah
that's a really difficult and really
good question
that's that eventually my point in the
nutshell i think they're equal okay so
so put it so let's put it so let's put
it in context a man your partner tells
this woman by text that i love you and i
want to be with you et cetera is that
worse than him going to miami and having
a one-night stand
[ __ ] you tonight i'm never going to
think
i'm very open to being
schooled on this but right now i feel
like they're equally bad that initial
shock of the one night stand normally
probably hits harder yeah
i'll say yeah that's interesting i would
i would pick the one night stand
as as as as wes or no no like that's
better yeah like yeah because there's no
emotional attachment i'd rather i'd
rather neither right sure
but also the the real issue here is not
that they cheated it's what's happening
in their relationship that caused them
to cheat in the first place he went to
miami and he was he saw a bag
like have you ever been to miami yeah
you've seen the girls that i get i'm
like they're beautiful they're like
that's like the most beautiful city
yeah
but a man a man
how can i put it like a man
a man cheating is like
emotional right so that's way more
harmful to the relationship
but yeah
physically if he's for example
has a one-night stand with somebody then
as pearl says it's like it's easier to
get over it's easier to get over right
100 worse emotionally because
if we're having sex you could be
thinking of her sure
so to me
if i'm thinking we're laying in bed
you're looking at my eyes we're doing
whatever you're thinking of her
that will mess me up more yeah than the
fact that you've gone to because that
says more about that says more about the
quality of your relationship being in
decline than a than a one-night stand
100 and and it's and in that sense
you're building when to cheat yeah
you're having all of those visuals in
your head
of
what you want to do to that woman
so to me that's much worse than a
one-night stand and one last time yeah
it will hurt
but my question would be like did you
protect yourself you had a condom yeah
all right cool no baby can become all
right
i have a question that sort of relates
to this why
must men put up with female hormones
like being emotional and crazy but women
cannot put up with male hormones like
being horny
corny
what do you think hannah
that's a good question
i think
it's
what society has put on us
where
women a woman's period mood swings
whatever it's normalized
but men
cheating on a woman is
demonized
but
um i'd say to some extent
because you come with this you know
polygamy relationship you could be more
than one person all of that they've made
that more normal like so to me
a man cheating on a woman
is more acceptance than a woman cheating
on a man if that makes sense so to me
you got all right your periods and a
woman feeling them muting but for me
that's just a myth because at the end of
the day a woman could be moody and just
not on a period she could just be a
moody woman period
also okay to answer the original
question when a woman has hormonal mood
swings
it's outside of a relationship like she
has them regardless whereas when a man
cheats it might hey it might not be to
do with his biology and b
he's doing something that offended the
relationship like specifically i think
it's just that they have so much more
testosterone
and so they're just like then why not so
if it's purely about sex why not just
have more sex with their woman or use
their she might not have the highest
sexual i just think men are men um
they're they they're programmed to want
sexual variety i don't think it's
anything personal with you or your
relationship
um a lot sometimes it is but like you
know i think a lot of times they just
that's just how men are
i'm not saying it's like a good thing or
men should cheat but
it's just kind of how they are
here's the thing right i am officially
going to sit on the fence for the first
time
because i completely agree with what you
are saying in the sense of imagining let
me make sure my wife's correct a man
shouldn't cheat in the sense of um
where he's at in his relationship so if
i if i've
contracted myself i'm only going to
sleep with you no one else
then a man should
abide by that contract however however
the same time i 100 agree with pearl in
the sense of
i personally have slept with a lot of
women from a lot of different cultures
from around the world right
so
in the sense of exploring my variety
hell yeah i'm gonna as a man with a high
sex drive i'm gonna want to do that
before before i settle down and be like
here take take my finances could you
ever be faithful to one woman you think
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not
could i yeah yeah
do you feel like most men can yeah i
feel like most men
who get what they want from their women
are happy yeah
yeah what and whatever they don't know
do you do you think most men can if
they're put in positions where women are
thrown at them constantly
no
okay yes yes um will they want to
probably not okay because yeah okay yeah
because i've heard the quote about like
tiger woods where they were saying like
yeah maybe it's gross what he did but i
also don't have a bus full of brazilian
supermodels waiting for me at the end of
the video
at the end of the course yeah
it's about it's about it's about it goes
back to that thing around um like
communication isn't it because most
people most people go into a
relationship and they go well i don't
most women and men have different
standards on what's considered cheating
and so on and so forth but most people
don't actually discuss that in their
relationship yeah
i think everyone's got different
boundaries as well exactly but nobody
discusses it
i want a quick yes or no is liking
another girl's pictures cheating no no
no no yes
who said yes i think why
because i would i wouldn't want my girl
on ig posting pictures
is a girl posting a thirst trap cheating
yes or no yeah
so i dropped the gun yeah
it could be considered cheeky but it's
not cheating okay
what is she posting um
bikini ass shot it could be it could
become it's unacceptable but is it
cheating no they're two different two
different things yeah i agree with that
what about having a work husband or work
wife
what does that
i've heard it but i think it means
different things for different people
yeah
they're not they're not they're not
hooking up but they do everything
together at work they eat at work every
day they talk to each other they're like
yeah my boyfriend did this my girlfriend
did that um
yeah
i'm i'm i'm fortunate
i'm fortunate my partner works at home
with me so yeah
i don't think
i think it's harmless i think there's
nothing really
in it could you could be this work
husband work my wife and you argue every
day
i mean you have your disagreements every
day and they just say oh yeah your work
husband and work wife
so i think it's harmless unless there's
an attraction and then there's a problem
yeah like whether whether it's cheating
or not just comes down to what the
couple has defined themselves yeah yeah
do you think most people have those
conversations early on
no no no do you know how many times i've
been accused of cheating in in all of my
relationships even even to the point
where women will be like i don't want a
relationship with you i like where we're
at right now right so in a sense we're
just we're just what's the word um
buddies right
we're just we're just sexual about
friends and benefits friends with
benefits friends with oh my god they
love that term right
um so when when it comes to say save me
and you are friends with benefits right
but then at the same time i'm feeling
paul so i'll chat to pearl real quick
like hey paul what are you saying you
good yeah blue bliss in the hood
bless in the hood
[Applause]
i'm glad you heard that that was awful
um but in the sense of like you might
get in a type of way because
i'm now talking to another female
but at the same time we haven't you've
clearly said no i'm happy with what we
are right now
but then do have you felt hurt by doing
that to why you've gone now to a next
woman no
because i at the same time i've said to
you
if you don't want something concrete
then we can stay fluid right but then
but here but here goes back to what just
said communication
because i feel with some men
you might say okay what is this and we
say oh yes friends benefits or it's just
this is just sex whatever and you're
like cool so i'm gonna go to the next
woman because that next one was gonna
show me more attention so i'm gonna go
over there but the truth of the matter
is
it might have bugged you and if it
bugged you that's fine to say you know
what this is how i feel but again if you
feel you're showing your emotions your
class is weak because you're a man but
then if you're being not real to
yourself then you're going to let your
blessings walk away here's here's the
thing with me right i have always kept
it 100 with
anyone i've dealt with
would you say that most girls you tell
them but they don't listen
um yeah
i would yeah
for the same example i'm using right now
i've told her i have only date to to
prolong our relationship so for example
if i'm dating you on a serious thing
i'm looking for marriage i'm looking for
for kids at the end of it yeah i want to
be 60 years deep you on my deathbed
talking about you shouldn't have smoked
so much do you know what i mean
i don't i don't i don't i don't deal
with the
the frivolous sex
that's not going to peel me
because you
because because you've done it yeah i've
been there done that got many t-shirts
yeah
and they make it worse you're not gonna
make my toes pop
i just the common thing like i hear from
women is men don't want to commit
or that men aren't up front but the
thing i hear from men is that we tell
them that we don't want to commit and
they still do it anyway
would you say that's accurate or
inaccurate
yeah that's 100 accurate because hear
what men ain't got time to run up and
down chase
one girl two girlfriend it gets out of
hand
we just want here's what we want no
headache peace
i think if a man found the woman he
wanted to be where he would marry him as
quick
yeah
when when men say they don't want to
commit they mean they don't want to
commit to that girl specifically
and the woman sees that as a challenge
of oh well let me try get him to commit
and then the woman ends up getting hurt
i agree and i i always say as i saying
you never let a man tell you twice that
they don't want you
well
strong
period don't ever let a man tell you
twice that they don't want you and
that's through experience and that's
through just learning because the more
you go and go for something that's not
going to be there you're just literally
going to hurt yourself
so yeah
can a man change a woman or a woman
change a man which one's more likely
i think women try to change men yeah
more than try to change women
well
women can change men's
perspective a lot but they can't change
their innate
being if you like so when i got with my
missus i didn't want a relationship and
i told her that from the gate
i said no no
yeah
but again it comes back to what
discussed earlier right patience right
because she was there and she just did
her thing she stuck around you know what
i mean she had that patience she had
that
she had that tenacity that i hadn't seen
before so she brought something
different that i wasn't used to
so that's interesting because i would
hate i don't like false hope i find i
get a lot of false hope if you say how
was that girl going and she said oh she
just wants to be friends now and people
will say oh you never know she might
change her mind but i'm like it's been
six years now should she yeah no no no
no no no
it's not a good thing don't don't try
how long from when you first started
seeing her um until you actually dated
her was it
when you say singing dating i i don't i
don't first i don't know i don't know
how you guys met but like first
date or whatever it was yeah like actual
girlfriend oh
like eight nine months
between six and nine months that's a
long time between six from them yeah
yeah
veteran periods have to be strong
solidified
yeah because it's interesting because
it seems like like that it's almost like
there's talking now before dating and
it's interesting because when you talk
to like like i've talked to my grandma
about some of these concepts and she's
like what on earth is going on
so this is a question that was kind of
from we're talking about earlier
why is it okay for women to feel
entitled to be protected and provided
for but it's wrong for a man to feel
entitled to sex and intimacy
[Music]
social social constructs isn't it
i call it
an [ __ ] question
if you say it if you ask it you become
an [ __ ] so
why haven't we had sex i want you to
lose weight suddenly you're the [ __ ]
for saying these questions
um i would say
easy because law is written masculine
so explain
so
if you look at the
english law if it was based on english
law it's written he
him
himself
um
so that double standards has
in terms of in terms of from the english
culture point of view
it's just organic
i don't understand what you're saying
because a lot of the laws like favor
women i would say and not men i would
say like all
laws exactly so in terms of the
prosecution of it right it's based
masculine so for example a woman can't
be accused of grape right right yes yes
because there's no penetration it's like
do you know he penetrated
saying yeah so
that's why that's where the double
standard comes in is it in the sense of
well
i can do what you do and not get
prosecuted for it mm-hmm do say it in
the middle it's wrong for you right but
okay for me mm-hmm
what do you guys think why why is it um
why do we expect men
uh i forgot what the question was oh
yeah why is it okay for women to feel
entitled to be protected and provided
for but it's wrong for a man to feel
entitled to sex and intimacy what do you
guys think
i think the question should be reframed
where the
the men should be entitled to a woman
who submits to his leadership instead of
sex because then it's both more of an
emotional
um
currency between the two
but then in that case i don't think that
is fair
yeah
i i don't think
anyone is entitled to anything no one
really owes you anything yeah yeah
because at the end of the day
um a man shouldn't be entitled to have
sex with any woman they want
because it's a woman's body and no woman
should be entitled to be protected by a
man because of the enemy if they're a
woman just because they're a woman yeah
but if you're in a relationship
if you're married if you're in a
relationship if you're married bro oh my
god if i was married and a robber came
in
yeah and he would pretend
that's true but then you go back to
in the relationship
i think he would be entitled to sex if
he's married
he will be entitled to sex but would you
feel you need to give it to him all the
time yes
even if you don't want to yeah it's a
you show up to your job and you don't
want to that's your job your wife that's
a very that's a very good comparison
i mean like sure you can have a sick day
like but you only get so many sick days
a year before you start counting your
days i heard that
i heard that question
i hear that is is it you just suddenly
stopped wanting sex the other one wants
it so one of you is well i i think it's
because a lot of women marry their
second choice and so it's not actually
someone they want they just you know
they got the kids and now they're good
would you say would you say a lot of
women are entitled
what to be protected yeah
um
to some extent yeah
and but i will go back to like
being a woman
and looking at the type of woman who
they are kind of thing and i would say
as a woman there are some women that
don't really do much in their
relationship they don't do no effort
and you feel like you actually have got
a good guy
and
why do you think you're entitled to have
all of these things and you're not
bringing up the table and it's not just
about sex because this is the other
thing are women just to design to have
sex
is that all they can bring to the
relationship if is it just front and
that's it it's because then that's the
problem
it's not just sex but if if you don't
have sex guys don't want to get married
that's like a big reason they get
married like if you told dude okay
there's no sex involved
they're not they're not getting people
you have to get married to have sex
that's the thing you can get sex
anywhere you don't need to go through
that that thing about i need to get
married but what pearl's saying is that
if you're in a relationship the woman
expects the man to stay with that one
woman but then the man is not allowed to
expect that woman to always want to have
sex with him
like and especially especially with the
big risk that men take today
because men take such a big risk if they
get married because you can leave take
half and take their kids
that's a lot of that's a lot of power to
give a woman but they won't so if
they're if they're willing to do that
it's like hell give just give him sex
when he wants
so what if a man has um an accident or
something happen to him and what is he
still expected to protect that woman the
same way he before that accident is it
good is he it's a different type of
protection isn't it it doesn't always
have to be physical financial it's the
mindset of being a protector and a
provider and that's why
men think that it's all about money but
really a woman cares equally much about
his mindset of being a provider than how
much he actually makes because there's
men who make you know multiple six
figures and they don't believe in
being a provider and then there's also
men who make 50k a year but they have
that provider and they have good
leadership skills and they have good
levels of integrity good levels of
communication etc
yeah that's what i think it's nothing to
do
with money because money is just money
money income money can go well it's a
big part of it
i think i think it's competence that
women are more attracted to than money
it's like it's a guy that's smart and
that tends to go with money but if you
can win the lottery tomorrow he's not
hot yeah like money is just a byproduct
of the traits that you have it's the
mindset around the money as well i think
i watched a youtube video and it wasn't
having money it was
the ability to make it yes that's what
they found attractive
yeah it's like you find it more
attractive if a guy has money lost it
and then made it again yeah because it
shows resilience or something yeah
but like you could i mean i i would if a
dude won the lottery he's not hot to you
and as soon as the money goes you will
be too
you wouldn't trust anything he does he
was all based on luck yeah
yeah
that's but that's it's not i wouldn't
say that's to do with the money that's
to do with the person not being honest
and that's the person not being honest
in all aspects is just because money has
been the factor of what he's lying about
but if a person can't communicate about
being honest you know what this happened
you know lost my job couldn't help with
the house couldn't do this that's
communication so the issue is not to do
with how much money he's got and the
money he has is the issue that he's not
able to say do you know what this is
happening this is the truth that's the
problem
might be a tangent but
with women going off to make their own
money does that make is that the reason
why money has become so important no
women might have to make their own money
because we're living in the time where
petrol is nearly two pounds yeah
everyone has that's the issue but it's
nothing to do with oh i better make the
money because i need to be
the man of the house because i'm not a
man but it that's basically what it is
but the problem is it would be not
because oh he's got money now and he's
not got money so i'm going i've got a
problem because you couldn't come to me
as my man as me being a woman to say
this is what the issue is because
what how they look at relationship the
man is the head and i'm the neck so
basically you forgot that i was the neck
to support you
and it all goes back to ego
so i mean and that's what needs to
really kind of dismiss and go and that's
how relationship i believe couldn't work
well i think a lot of women think
they're better than guys when they make
more money than them that's ego yeah but
yeah but it's like
you're you're not in the same
competitiveness as what they value so if
you're not equally as fit feminine and
friendly as they are like in money um
and you know height or whatever whatever
it is
it's it's you can't ask for that just
because you make enough money like no
one's lining up to date oprah
but i think a lot of i think it's it's
like we're fed these lies as women like
about the things that men value and it
can be very confusing to women and
sometimes it's like it's it's too late
by the time we find out yeah
and that that could give mixed signals
for men because then they just think
women only want money so they just
chuckle their money at them and they're
still not gonna stay
it's kind of like when you ask woman
what makes you more dateable than the
other woman most women will say things
like i'm more educated or i have my own
cart when other women don't or i have a
good career and i'm independent
and those are admirable but they're not
the reasons why a guy would be sexually
attracted to you
so dating is almost like it sells right
like you're both selling your traits to
the other person and women are trying to
sell the wrong things to the man
i'm gonna take a second and read super
chats so guys
thank you so much for all of the
donations um this is going towards
getting a blessing two more cameras
right blessing
um we're also trying to get um like some
backdrops here so we can have some logos
and maybe
i don't know maybe a sponsor we'll see
we'll see um
okay so robert 20 super chat be a man f
nuts86 for the camera thank you sidney
jacob 30 and unemployed get this drunk
off the panel robert be a man silly
sausage the irrational fear of things
not working out stops women from
becoming wives they will not give up
options they see on instagram and and go
through childbirth unless you are with
without question unattainable again
jc pearl start
remordrey stevenson or chase edmonds i
don't know okay um thane metra there is
nothing like the 200 super chat let's
give it a clap
there is nothing like conditional
submission a broke farm worker in the
u.s gets submission and most men do not
you are either submissive or you're not
h r h raise 207 when a woman argues like
a man i start hearing a man but i see a
woman thane mitra beef beef beef 50
super chat for bee
[Music]
um
uh freeman r um pearl how did this
panel of capping betas sneak out of the
house
i think i think i read that one already
can we
respond to that yeah you got yeah yeah i
speak your piece
yeah
but quickly not not too long now it's
quick
what makes me a beta because like
i said that i don't lead with my money
and i heard they said it was like what
the [ __ ] he who's this four-year-old
drunkard yeah
i've had a bit of a drink come on the
podcast you have a drink too
that's what i'm gonna say
well i don't need with my money so if if
that's how you perceive me good on you
oh that's exactly how i want you to
perceive me i was about to keel over in
that toilet
boom
sweat in my ass
silly sausage has one more super chat
you come to love not by finding the
perfect person but seeing an imperfect
person perfectly
okay that's a good one that's a good one
is that an instagram quote
seen that before yeah it sounds familiar
a lot of these quotes be like going
around
um why
do we always hear about how men are
taught how to why are men taught how to
treat a woman but women are not taught
how to treat a man
double standard
can we just brush that off
also i don't believe that men nowadays
are taught how to treat a woman
i think less and less
men aren't taught the basic things
it's true though like it's very
counterintuitive that women
study how to be good in their career but
they don't study relationships when
knowing how to date is a skill that you
have to learn it's like going to the gym
and learning how to squat it's still a
skill it's not something that you can
expect
that will come naturally
what would you say are the basics that
people need to learn in relationships
for a man it should be hell to be a good
leader
there are men there are men nowadays who
they don't know how to at the very least
plan the date
they'll just ask the woman i don't know
what do you want to do
because because they're pleasing yeah
but i think it's because women sleep
with men without going on dates
so they don't like i think men do what
they're expected to do and a lot of men
don't have to do anything
but not a lot i should say a very small
percentage of men a lot a lot you mean
are you saying that men don't have to
try very hard because there's always
women available who vote yeah i'm i no
i'm saying a small percent so most one
out of three men are virgins who haven't
had sex in the past year anyone who's
like in this space knows that stat but
um like a very small percentage of men
don't plan dates because they don't need
to
because girls are like so readily
available to them they can go on tinder
they can go on instagram and a girl will
be there quick yeah so i think sometimes
it's like a reflection of the women
because like that's like we accept that
yeah it's it's on both right so it's on
the man where they have to know how to
at least be a good leader and plan the
day but it's also on woman collectively
to raise the standards so that
ma the man planning the date becomes a
norm not an exception but it's like i
think we if we raise the standards we
have to raise the value too
and it's tough because we're just not
what men want anymore like the average
age of one
that's not that's not youth
and and what what percent of girls at 31
are virgins
none
yeah
so
it's like
i don't know it's just kind of it's like
i always hear like women say raise your
standards but
if we don't have to be this done right
but a lot of times like we try to be the
we try to raise our standards after the
value is gone because women women
need to protect the value that we're
given
where men have to create value
and that's what needs to change is more
women need to
know how to be the standard that they're
setting for the man do you think if
birth control went away tomorrow how do
you think that would change the dating
market
i don't think it will make a difference
to be honest i don't think it would make
any difference people just pull out yeah
i don't really make a difference i think
inflation is way too high right now
women would be a lot more selective
about who they have sex with if they
accepted it
they wouldn't just go marching on it it
wouldn't happen it probably wouldn't
happen straight away but over time women
would become more selective about who
they're sleeping with
but i think what is of what it is
off-putting and what does happen a lot
of men the first thing that they do talk
about is sex
and it can be off-putting for women and
women has to say like you know you know
what i'm not doing this like if you
don't want to get to know me or take me
out on a date let's leave it because i'm
not i'm not taking that and then men
have a problem with that some men have a
problem with that i will say well
don't even men in their face oh yeah
oh well you'd be surprised
even in their 40s you'd be surprised
i don't i don't think most men start
with that i think a lot of men are
afraid of getting killed
like me too no no there is a lot of men
that are like that not maybe not a lot
of men that are in the social media
platform but there is a lot of men that
still out like that that still behave
like that that still expect to have that
that's basically they need to have it
um
i win a women's challenge i'd say no i'm
not interested or they've been having to
say anything just ignore them because
you're like what is the waste of time
waste of energy how does this start is
this like online or can i just have an
example it could be online yeah it could
be um a person could approach it speak
to you about i don't know it could be
anything and then all of a sudden i'm
like oh yeah um what knickers you
wearing really so yeah so so on the
street so on the street a guy will just
come up to you and then ask you what
knickers you're wearing sometimes yeah
well not even knickers or almost being
very
like there are men out there
not really i do get you know the
occasional cat call or the whole like oh
what's your number like you're beautiful
but i wouldn't say i've gotten some
super provocative things there's some
men not like like i said
i might not personally will get that all
the time but i will witness it or
you know social media i've had it
sometimes where i've had to block
certain but it happens what's worse is
it is it worse than social or is it
worse in person i think in both i think
the world that we live in right now and
i think because of covid and everything
can lock down and people just got more
enticed with social media and internet
everything
like
people don't know how to talk to people
people don't know how to communicate
people don't know how to approach a
person people don't even know how to
have a phone conversation
exactly just text me everything's text
voice note no let's have a conversation
let's see if we can actually speak for
five minutes and i'm still enticing the
conversation that'll be that'd be a nice
challenge
if social media went away tomorrow how
would that impact dating
i think it would improve it after a
while yeah you've got so much choice now
yeah it's just there's always a nicer
new person around the corner so you
might as well keep swiping i've never
done online dating no and i never would
people would have to be more selective
and they'd have to be more
more intelligent more sophisticated
about the way that they men would have
to be more sophisticated about the way
they approach women and women
you have to pick better so if you went
to a bar you couldn't ask one girl out
and then go ask another girl out and
then go back to the first and say all
right
[Music]
[Music]
well i think more men would approach
women in public and like maybe social
skills would improve yeah because you
don't have that option and to avoid
rejection i think women too
yeah like i said before i could see
everyone would go out more so yeah yeah
before i had laser eye surgery i was
technically ugly to like 99 of women
right until i got until i got removed my
glasses grew my hair
all of a sudden i'm attractive and i'm
six foot plus
so it doesn't matter if i've got a
mattress on the floor you're still
coming home with me you don't know what
is that
because you don't know that factor after
the fact
and then even then i'm cooking you
breakfast in the morning so
[ __ ] you're coming back for round two
because you like breakfast in the
morning forget the matches on the floor
yeah you know i mean but you don't have
to be these six figure guys to get to
get to to run the crutches
you get crutches if if you apply
something
yeah i just think if those like i feel
like a lot of problems would be solved
if we literally we got rid of birth
control on social media well yeah cause
women would have to be more selective
with who they sleep with yeah i mean
like maybe you know you said pull out
but like options they actually have
what do you think is the biggest
challenge for women when it comes to
social media and what they see on a
daily basis
um i think it inflates like women's ego
so like i think a lot of times we think
we're hotter than we are right
yeah to add to your point pearl i feel
like there's a date and inflation going
on at the minute yeah in a sense of
where you've got all these
like fives and sixes
who used to be able to get at a push
seven or eight
who are now gone [ __ ] them seven and
eights we want tens out of
you know what i'm saying i think women's
social media has heightened women's ex
uh social media has heightened women's
expectations of what it is that they
desire in a man it's just like took it
through the roof and it's like they
expect
you know 25 out of 10
type of man every single time
so
it gives men this like perception that
the average girl is actually super super
hot because if we look at how many
relationships are struggling because the
guy likes random girls pictures on the
internet and also how many women are
comparing themselves to other women on
instagram what do you think about that
i'm curious
of which part a man liking a woman's
pictures on instagram
it's contextual based on what the
picture is who the woman is like if it's
a friend that he met before me who
happens to a female who happens to be a
girl totally fine if it's
he's never seen before from
america yeah i don't i don't think
that's okay
but i also think that a guy who's got
sexual discipline wouldn't want to do
that in the first place like my
boyfriend doesn't follow any bikini
models on instagram it's not because i
told him to unfollow them he just
doesn't yeah
and that speaks a lot to the that speaks
a lot to the values that you play in
that relationship as well that would be
a waste of time anyway there's no point
liking all these people on social media
they're just gorgeous because it just
inflates them as well all fifteen
hundred thousand people like me in this
bikini yeah
i saw
i saw it on tinder and one girl i knew
she was on only fans because i looked on
her instagram and then i went on it and
then she said follow me on instagram
like i'm not going on your only fans and
yeah i'm meeting people in real life and
then on her instagram was hi hi i met
you on tinder i met you on tinder and
not getting involved she's probably got
an assistant to try to sell you on her
only fans
i'm good yeah i'm not i'm not paying
if i
if i was seeing good and i see a girl
with like thousands of likes
it's like a it's like an impulse not to
yeah not to join the crowd because i
don't want to be part of a crowd i want
to be part of 15 000 people what's that
about do you know what's funny right i
know i've got a couple of friends who
i've known from back in school who have
now obviously become they were
attractive at school era and now they've
become like these insta not not in this
instagram models but they
they use their attractiveness to make
money right
and
when i when i when i see them i i see
their post and i'm like well you got 10
000 likes
boy if that's like linda dm's i'm not
getting i'm not even kidding i'm not
getting into in it because again you
know my mattress on the floor and that
so um
but at the same time they'll hit me back
and be like yo
what are you saying you're good
you bless yeah i'm like yeah
but i said it's all materialistic
you know what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying if social media went away like
we need to bring back meeting people in
person and having conversations in
person and speaking on the phone hundred
percent
even
you know something i did when i got to
london because here it's like less
friendly i think
and so i had this idea i was like i'm
gonna just say hi to people walking down
the street and like see how many say hi
back and i've never gotten so many crazy
looks
i was like hi and then they were just
looking like i'm nuts but i'm from
chicago and i'm from the suburbs you
could just do that but yeah here i guess
it's like they grabbed hold of their
wallet or their purse
yeah yeah i think i had one or two
the fact that
says she's from chicago came
i know people in london think chicago is
like crazy and it is but i'm not i'm not
from like the crazy
you came from chicago which is has its
reputation as a whole yeah you came to
london thinking that people are going to
say hi to you
i was hoping i was stupid
okay well i think i'm gonna close out
the show so um why don't we go around
any final thoughts funny super chats you
want to speak your piece on you know go
ahead
i'll start off off the bat i'm not a
beta
all right
blackberry blackberry productions
presents the chop
like and subscribe and you'll see what
i'm about that's it all right that's all
i got to say yeah not not a beta guys
[Music]
um all i can say from this discussion
just be truthful to yourself i think to
be truthful to yourself
then it's easier to um be truthful to
others as well and that's how you can
just be healthy in any sort of
relationship that you enter as well
um so yeah and if you want to learn more
follow choose debate 2020 instagram
um
mine would be i'm just trying to get on
my comfort zone so you do the things
that you're not
expected to do and then eddie ain't here
but if my second book ever becomes a
movie and he can do a brooklyn accent i
want him as a role model
my final thoughts for both men and women
are
stop focusing on
where do i find a good partner and start
focusing on becoming the kind of partner
that
you would want
i would say final thoughts is to
communicate the value of what you want
and be clear on what the standards of
what you want in your relationship to
make it successful
ah now for hella narcissistic i was like
i'm not obey them
um so i'm gonna read the last couple of
super chats so gorilla inbound are y'all
on spotify no but we will be soon um i
know you guys have been getting on me to
get on spotify i'm sorry
i just haven't got to it yet we will
i'm not going to give you a date though
because i don't want to disappoint you
maurice um anti-folk um the beta in the
dreads looks like that annoying drunk
uncle in my village freedom r i
apologize you are not a beta you are a
alpha bisexual okay
ky crows be um it's hard to lead with
money if you don't have any and then
that was the last super chat i believe
since the last one i'm gonna refresh it
real quick a couple announcements for
the channel we're just gonna go over
again um we have two clips channels so
make so make sure you subscribe to both
just pearly clips and pearl daily um
follow my instagram just dot pearly
things sign up for our memberships we
have the five dollar tier where you get
to be a part of the chat the ten dollar
tier where you get to see our
behind-the-scenes blogs the three the
third tier which you connect with us on
social media and the fourth tier where
you get a one-on-one session once a
month with me so if you want like
youtube help or you know help with your
life
i'll do my best um member of the week
dragon stallion1001
um dm eddie the link is in the
description to his instagram if you want
to come on the show don't forget to
subscribe if you have watched two or
more videos and you don't subscribe we
have beef okay
like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time